foreign
T joins us up next in Salt Lake City
Brent welcome to the Ramsay show
glad to be here thanks for having me on
sure how can we help
okay
um I have some cash which it's about 55
000 all right in in my credit union
and
I'm really afraid of this economy the
way it sits right now so
um what are you afraid of
um the collapse
based on
well yeah
in the past you know I mean in past
history the bank the government has come
in and shut down Banks and taken
people's money granted it's been
100 years ago basically you know I mean
it could happen couldn't it
Anything could happen but what's likely
to happen do you think all of your money
is going to disappear in that bank
well I have a lot more in that bank than
just this cash and it's insured correct
it's insured correct up to 250 000 per
person on the account per person do you
have more than that in one account
um well I have two separate accounts in
stocks
and
um well you can't be that scared since
all your money's there what what's the
fear of driving all this all of a sudden
listen to all these YouTube videos yeah
so so that's yeah so Fear mongering
clickbait YouTube videos yeah I mean
listen if that's all you do is pay
attention to conspiracy theories and all
these things that could happen then it's
gonna absolutely uh impact you and and
so I don't want to Discount what your
fears are what you believe your
philosophies on government I'm not I
don't want to get down into that but I
would say this
the worst I mean you know you start
concocting the worst case scenario and
could it happen I guess who knows the
percentage chances you can't argue about
that because no one knows the percentage
chance of any of that happening but
could it happen sure but what do you I
mean living life requires you to make
some smart decisions based on
the realities of what's working the
stock market mutual fund performance all
that stuff has got history
um and and that's what you know but but
deciding what to do with your money
based on something that you don't know
is going to happen that doesn't get you
anywhere at all so unless you're
planning to go to a bunker somewhere and
and and you know live off of the
chickens and off grid and you know bury
your money in coffee tins
then then you know you know what to do
you know what to do with that money
yeah I know I I stop watching the
YouTube apocalyptic videos first of all
that's why I've been watching you
instead that's good we're we got a head
on our shoulders and uh
well what is there a question underneath
all this that we can help with today
well and I've got a I just retired and
now I've got a 401k that's gonna I've
got to do something with two pass in a
Roth and the half is half of it's in a
traditional that you know do I take it
out or do I just leave it there and let
it ride
well do you need the money what are you
living off of right now no
um both my wife and I retired I just
retired the first or the end of December
uh combined we live off of about 8
000 a month and where does that come
from
um her retirement from the government
and my retirement from Social Security
and
um
so between the pension and social
security you guys aren't even touching
retirement accounts
oh no what's the total of your nest egg
two three
with our house because our house is paid
for basically what's the house worth
six was worth eight at high peak so 600
000. what do you have in retirement
accounts
um
probably close to 400. okay
but it sounds like from the pension and
social security you guys are covered so
that 400 can continue to grow
yeah yeah
I just don't want to lose it well I mean
you'll have required minimum
distributions on those eventually if the
on the traditional side
yeah so that's the only thing you'll
have to worry about
um but you're not going to lose it it's
not going to disappear into the abyss
worst case do you have any kids it'll be
passed down to
yes okay well that's a great blessing
and Legacy for them is it a good is it a
good thing to put uh set up a trust and
whatever get everything put into a trust
at this point in time if you'd like to
if there's a very specific way you want
this money distributed with terms and
conditions and some strings attached
then it's a wise thing to look into
yeah yeah plus I have insurance you know
my life insurance do you have a will in
place
we have a living will right now but it's
it's it's fairly old we need to we need
to do something and update it I'm sure
I'd get all of that in order and I would
sleep well at night and get off the
YouTube channels Brent you're doing
great you guys have a great retirement
income even without touching those
accounts but I just let it ride and uh
there's some great tax strategies you
can use with the Roth versus traditional
side so I'd connect with a smartvester
pro if you want to figure out how to
best utilize that money down the line